patrick turcotte voulait se mettre
davantage de bonheur dans la vie de ses
300 employés cette aire située derrière
son entreprise de camionnage de la
région de drummondville lui permettent
aujourd'hui de parvenir à ses fins j'ai
vu le bout de terrain qui était
inutilisé qui était prêté au voisin pour
de la grande culture et j'ai dit ça
serait vraiment une bonne place pour
faire pousser des légumes pour les
employés on cherche toutes sortes
d'idées pour se réinventer des moyens de
rétention ont gardé nos employés il a
donc embauché maraîchère est une équipe
qui ont rapidement mis la parcelle de
terre à profit on fait beaucoup de
choses on fait nos pommes de terre ont
fait des carottes on fait des petites
failles ya toutes les crises faire donc
les choux vert rouge le brocoli
chou-fleur on essaye de faire du chou de
bruxelles d'un combat mais au fait du
projet cet ami et entrepreneurs en
solutions numériques s'est jointe à
l'aventuré pour redonner au suivant nos
travailleurs numéro 6 le plaisir puis le
plaisir baisse sa nnsa au grand plaisir
un gros il ya un plaisir puis de pour
redonner aussi ou suivant autant à
l'interné qu'à l'externe
environ 120 paniers de légumes frais à
prix modiques sont offerts chaque
semaine aux employés intéressés c'est
sans compter les surplus distribués au
comptoir alimentaire drummond
l'initiative semble de toute évidence
apprécié par les principaux intéressés
ça nous permet de bénéficier de bons
légumes bio toute la semaine ça prouve
quand employeurs pensent à nous petits
bouts de garder pour le prix c'est pas
intéressant sur la qualité des légumes
sur le teint on y vit dans la literie
avec l'arrivée de ces pôles etc par les
entrepreneurs ne manquent manifestement
pas d'idées pour continuer à soutenir
leurs employés ici jean françois dumas
radio-canada de romandie